das muss proaktiv letztlich von der
regierung kommen von den politischen
entscheidungsträgern und dann kann das
letztlich die armee auch umsetzen und
diesen dieses sich verlassen auf
bürokratische gänge von unten nach oben
und bis die anträge vorliegen und so
weiter ich verhalte das nicht mehr
verlage gerecht deutschland ist quasi in
einem katastrophalen zustand was die
pandemie anbelangt und wir sind hier
massiv gefordert und müssen da endlich
auch proaktiv rein und das in top
downloads von oben nach unten und es
kann nicht sein dass jeder
ministerpräsident sein eigenes ding
dreht hier in dieser krise nicht das
muss wirklich gesteuert werden aus dem
kanzleramt ich sage es nochmal trotz der
rechtlichen grauzone ich meine so ein
bisschen so an esprit was helmut schmidt
1962 bei der flutkatastrophe in hamburg
hat er das wäre jetzt angezeigt nicht
und ich kann es auch nicht mehr hören
als bürger diese talkrunden mit denen
ihnen die verschärfungen wollen und die
anderen die es lockerer sehen und
zweiter mir fehlte wirklich die
stringente politische führung aus einem
guss und das krisen-management ressort
übergreifend fokussiert auf die
hauptrisikogruppe auf die ich wiederhole
noch mal alten und pflegeeinrichtungen
das fehlt mir